وضع انساني كارثي في غزه مع استمرار القصف
الكثيف والاستهداف المتعمد للبنى التحتيه
لليوم الخامس على التوالي الصور الجويه
التي رصدناها اظهرت تدمير احياء باكملها
خاصه وسط وشمال قطاع غزه وعدد الشهداء
تجاوز الفا حتى الان فش ميه يتغسلوا فيش
ميه يشربوا شرب ميه
بنعبر وما زاد هذا الوضع الصعوبه انقطاع
المياه وايضا الكهرباء بشكل كامل قبل قليل
بعد نفاد الوقود اللازم لتشغيل شركه
التوليد هذا الانقطاع دق ناقوس الخطر في
القطاع الصحي بشكل اكبر من غيره خاصه ان
المستشفيات هي بالاصل غير قادره على
استيعاب اعداد الشهداء والمصابين الكبيره
بسبب نقص الامكانيات والمستلزمات الطبيه
بالاضافه الى تعرض اكثر من ع مراكز طبيه
للاستهداف ما اخرجها عن الخدمه وزاد هذا
الضغط
مطشم على صعيد المساعدات الانسانيه
العاجله التي يحتاجها سكان غزه كما نعلم
اسرائيل تمنع دخول اي شي حتى انها هددت
بقصف اي شاحنه تدخل عنري معبررفح المنذ
الوحيد لسكان القط المحصر
[موسيقى]
اما بالنسبه للنازحين الامم المتحده قالت
ان اكثر من 260 الف فلسطيني على الاقل
تركوا منازلهم جراء القصف المتواصل معظم
هؤلاء لجؤوا الى مدارس الونر وطبعا هذا
العدد مرشح
للارتفاع نداءات الاستغاثه العاجله
للمجتمع الدولي ومنظماته بضروره التحرك
السريع لايقاف ما وصف بالجريمه ضد
الانسانيه لم تنجح حتى الان لا بحمايه
الانسان في غزه ولا حتى الحيوان الف سلامه
عليك حسبي الله في الاحتلال والله الف
سلامه
عليك